valérie pécresse mettra fin au laxisme
migratoire en reprenant le contrôle de
nos frontières objectif maîtriser les
flux migratoires nous ferons voter par
le parlement des quotas migratoires
maximum pour diviser par deux
l'immigration et par trois le
regroupement familial nous ferons
supprimer les visas des pays qui ne
reprennent pas leurs clandestins nous
organiserons l'asile à la frontière et
nous supprimerons les prestations
sociales non contributives aux étrangers
qui ont moins de 5 ans de séjour
régulier en france avec valérie pécresse
les expulsions seront vraiment appliquée
nous rétablirons les tests osseux pour
déterminer l'âge réel des migrants qui
se revendique mineurs nous obligeront
les clandestins à quitter le territoire
français et nous expulserons les
étrangers condamnés à l'issue de leur
peine nous exigerons l'assimilation des
nouveaux arrivants en france nous
instaurons un examen de maîtrise du
français avant de délivrer un titre de
séjour nous mettrons fin à
l'automaticité du droit du sol enfin
nous fixerons un plafond d'élèves non
francophones par classe pour faciliter
l'intégration